okay we're here on overtime
overtime is back
we're
where we answer your questions
[Laughter]
uh now that recreational marijuana use
is becoming legal in more states and is
gaining in popularity will lawmakers
ever admit that the war on drugs was
basically ineffective well you're the
only lawmaker here
i should have admitted it 10 years ago i
mean we i don't understand how we can't
legalize marijuana in this country it's
the you should think that that's one
thing we can get bipartisan support for
it's building now
nancy mace i think yeah she's a
republican yeah she's the one who i said
this years ago i said the republicans
are going to steal this issue from the
democrats if the democrats don't jump on
it she's the one introducing legislation
to nationally make marijuana legal i
mean yeah it's funny i once interviewed
pablo escobar's son sebastian marrakeen
and he said to me escobar yeah his son
not not it used to be called pablo
escobar junior but he changed his name
for obvious reasons and he said to me
that's not el chapo no no no no he's the
original og it's escobar right not
really yeah he's the one from like right
exactly
marco
[Laughter]
his son said to me the only thing my
father truly feared was the legalization
of drugs right because it would have
been worse
well so did al capone worry about liquor
being legal yes exactly and one of the
tragedies as you know i wrote a whole
book about this called chasing the
scream one of the tragedies of this is
there are so many people dying in this
country who would have lived if they had
been in safe portugal where they
decriminalized all drugs right all the
money they currently spend on they used
to spend on [ __ ] people's lives up
shaming them and imprisoning them
prisoning them and spent it all instead
on turning their lives around and they
went from having the worst drug problem
in the european union to the lowest drug
problem in the european union that
enormous numbers of people are dying who
could live we'll say
that magazine's brilliant on this point
yeah that question did ask when are we
going to admit the whole war on drugs
was a mistake not just the marijuana bit
so i'm i'm waiting for the rest as well
on this issue
and there's a there's a wait there's a
gauntlet thrown down
what do you make of that well it's not
just pot
are you for anything else being legal i
i'm for looking at the decriminalization
of certain drugs but let's start with
the marijuana justice act and let's
start let's start with just like in real
life we start with pot
that's great and we move on to it we
move on
marijuana legalization is the gateway
drug to legalizing everything else i am
a thousand percent right and it's
important for people to know that
legalizing drugs um means different
things for different drugs in the same
way that here it's legal to own a dog a
monkey and a lion but the rules are
different right in the same way
different countries have legalized drugs
in different ways switzerland for
example legalized heroin if you've got a
heroin problem they assign you to a
clinic you get it legally since they did
that you know how many people have died
on legal heroin in the 15 years since
they did that
zero not one person more people have
died since we started doing this [ __ ]
overtime of heroin overdoses in this
country that have died in the 15 years
of legal heroine in switzerland you can
own a lion
[Applause]
didn't you watch tiger king
of course i did not watch tiger king
of course i wouldn't patronize something
like that
you could no interesting it's i i no
just know i i you know i once went to a
party this guy had a a camel in the
[ __ ] there was something in a
building
he had a
yes i was like you know that one thing
if you had a big baller mansion out in
the with a lot of it's an ability
there's a camel in the lobby
they get up to his apartment and there's
a a tiger in the back and like i said
i'm a peterborough i was like i started
in mega in the united states or
something this was in that way
you could you could rent a camel to have
in your life i don't know it was a
christmas i don't know what the [ __ ] it
was and i started making i was getting
madder and madder and madder and there
was celebrities there i started to get
them involved saying tell this guy
he's a friend of mine you let the camel
loose
no but
i'm almost got everybody behind me and
arnold schwarzenegger walks in and goes
where's the tiger
that's pretty good
catherine which country most closely
resembles a libertarian-run government
and what could america learn from them
uh i regret to inform you that america
most resembles a libertarian-run
government which means that we are a
long way from libertarian ideals but in
the whole world i think so at this point
i mean you know there are bits and
pieces of other places that i would love
to see us borrow but i think that
there's
um
you know the
the thing that i think people who are
asking that question mean is they they
mean to say
hey you know where's your libertarian
paradise maybe it can't work or maybe
sometimes they like somalia jokes um and
you know i think i think that really
misses the point which is that for me
libertarianism is directional it's it's
let's go toward more freedom let's give
people more choices let's let people
make their own decisions where we can
and
maybe we're never going to get to an
ideal i don't think i think a lot of
political ideals are like that but in
the u.s we really do have very very
powerful
founding principles and norms that
conform to libertarianism a lot of ways
we let people
make their own choices we let people
bear the consequences of those choices
i mean we tax way too much especially in
this state
but uh
you're still here bill
still here is that is that the bench i'm
just still here i'm alive
speaking of marijuana legalization the
state also has taxed way too much on
that and kept the black market alive but
as much as we tax
uh
we do i mean we don't limit uh somebody
once put it this way it won't cut down
the tall trees right and i know all the
immigrants i know like from from
countries where like you think oh you're
that you're from france that's not a
country people usually like oh i got to
get out of here
or canada they say that's why i want to
be here because there is still here a
sense of freedom there's so many shitty
things about this country but you can
invent yourself reinvent yourself over
and over and you can get as high up in
the tree no one will will stop you where
they don't feel that in france right and
i think i think the
the reason that that's so important is
not just because individual people want
that for themselves it's also because we
have huge problems this world has huge
problems right and i really don't think
we're going to solve them by rearranging
the resources we have we're not going to
solve them by taxing a little more here
and moving the money we're going to
solve them by innovating we're going to
solve them by somebody thinking up
something big and new
and america makes space for that in a
way that other countries don't all right
thank you very much
thank you
you